hey what's going on is bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday February 27th 2017 what's going
on
how's it going sorry the podcast is a
little bit late this week
you know [ __ ] checkout was you know
10:00 a.m. at this place I was staying
at and I thought I could sleep till
10:00 and then do the [ __ ] podcast
and leave at noon that's what I thought
you know I'm sorry am I still in America
checkout time is maybe 11 where the [ __ ]
is at 10 a.m. the [ __ ] is Trump not
president anymore I mean I thought this
was something that he thought he thought
he was gonna make it great again make it
great again happy checkout at one in the
[ __ ] afternoon don't you sign an
executive order order for that your
orange headache [ __ ] how about that his
podcast it's not funny it's sad it's a
lonely man by himself sorry for the bad
Trump impression anyways I am in
Gainesville Florida right now you're
probably wondering bill what the [ __ ]
are you doing in Gainesville Florida
home of the Florida Gators you know
you're on there they're in a [ __ ]
Monday and it's not football season why
are you here it's because I have to do
the makeup date for the show that I was
gonna do back in November when I was
gonna go to the Florida Gators game down
there at the [ __ ] swamp I was gonna
do that and go to the Florida Gator LSU
game and that game got rained out
whatever they had a [ __ ] hurricane
and everything freaked out cuz
Jacksonville was gonna get the [ __ ]
kicked out of him gay Gainesville was
you know as far as I'm concerned it was
safe you know my complete lack of a
meteorology chol background is that the
right word I don't know so I'm back here
I'm back here you know in February when
nothing's going on oh [ __ ] what about
that team what if they [ __ ] team has
a good basketball team as a game tonight
maybe that's it maybe that's what's
going on I don't [ __ ] know anyways
I'm here in [ __ ] day Gainesville I
had a great time this whole weekend
being out there and not date
Daytona Beach Florida and Jesus Christ
dude
some of the [ __ ] locals in Daytona ya
heart just goes out too you know I mean
it's just easties [ __ ] all these it's
all those people that that people in
Hollywood trash you know what I mean
it's just a bunch of you know a lot of
[ __ ] white people that are just Jesus
life is just [ __ ] kicked the [ __ ] out
of them not saying everybody but I'm
just sayin
I [ __ ] came into town and [ __ ]
walking down the street the first night
I got video of this I'm walkin there's
like a fight about ready to break out
outside of a peach a joint and everybody
there was like my age except they look
my age you know what I mean they might
have a better hairline which isn't hard
with me but they're just [ __ ] fat
[ __ ] big fat [ __ ] was that prilosec
[ __ ] that people eat that wasn't called
that [ __ ] Larry the Cable Guy talks
about right no he goes [ __ ] pilot 680
seat when you [ __ ] go out you eat a
whole [ __ ] pig and your stomach's
like what the [ __ ] to just do to me
rather than not eating the whole [ __ ]
pig again you can take this [ __ ] and
I'll make it feel like eating a whole
pig yourself is okay that's [ __ ] they
had those bodies a lot of cargo shorts
that was just frayed at the bottom a lot
of bad tattoos a lot of [ __ ] people
that look like even if they weren't on
drugs you know when people do drugs for
so [ __ ] long there's only so coherent
that you can get back to we went to this
[ __ ] restaurant right on the strip
and there's [ __ ] Lady Jesus Christ
if she wasn't high she just done she's
just done so many [ __ ] drugs she
bought the [ __ ] wings over right and
they were like I'm they weren't ice cold
they were room temperature which is
[ __ ] ice cold and I'm like yeah and I
hate scented food back we're sitting in
this [ __ ] restaurant right and we're
sitting in it's like basically a NASCAR
because we're there to go to the Daytona
500 the next day right it's like a
NASCAR
that they cut in half and put a boost in
them in the middle of it right or some
[ __ ] I don't know what the [ __ ] it is
and we looked up later and evidently
this was the worst restaurant it mate
ended up going to this [ __ ] thing
ended up being the worst restaurant it
wasn't bad I ordered the [ __ ] it
looks Shady and the music they were
playing they were playing like ZZ Top
she's got legs
they played George Thorogood twice
they played yes owner of a lonely heart
I was just sitting there it felt like I
was 1985 I was joking on stage that
night I was waiting [ __ ] Marty McFly
to come walking in keyword there fly and
there was just some guy walking around
sort of mildly the words to this Joe and
it wasn't even a good George Thorogood
song it wasn't bad to the bone or that
whatever that [ __ ] whistle one
whiskey one scotch or one beer wasn't
that one it was that the that cover
event that my back door my [ __ ] don't
come no more moving on over rockin on
over it's just sitting there going oh my
god
the waitress [ __ ] up every possible
way she could have [ __ ] up other than
just blowing her nose into the bread I
mean other than that she's every [ __ ]
thing you could do she [ __ ] up it was
hilarious
I felt bad for I could see you know she
just you know we all do it we all do it
in my business we stay out there too
long
Madonna did it you know she's still
twerk and she's like 60 it's like
Madonna for the love of [ __ ] God can
you dress your age okay could you have a
shred of [ __ ] decency for yourself so
that people can just any general sense
look in your direction you know what I
mean there was a bunch of guys down on
Daytona Beach dressing the way Madonna
was dressing there was a bunch of
[ __ ] guys my age still wearing tank
tops where your arms have no muscle
definition anymore it's just it looks
like you know what it looks like it
looks like you know when somebody has
like cankles
you know that part of the leg or it just
you know there's no shape to the calf
that's what the arm looks like and it's
all [ __ ] flabby and just these awful
horrific [ __ ] tattoos just [ __ ] you
pick off a wall somebody with the shakes
just puts it on your [ __ ] arm and so
she comes over by the way when you go
into a place like that because once I
sit down I'm not leaving just go with
the grilled cheese you get a grilled
cheese sandwich and what can they do you
know what I mean [ __ ] Nate ordered a
hamburger and I was just like all right
through you know but if you get [ __ ]
Ebola I mean I don't want to hear you
bitching about it or what it would echo
lie whatever you get in it was something
with me so she comes over and she's just
saying hey well it was like 1:00 in the
afternoon the Sun just [ __ ] blazing
through the windows just like hey
welcome I'm gonna be your waitress for
this evening evening and she caught
herself saying evening and she just
[ __ ] plowed forward uh you know in
specials here you have ice and it was
like listen it was likely listening to a
cellphone going in and out right and she
brings the [ __ ] orders over and she
kept going how's your meat I've never
heard anybody say that I ordered a
burger and the winks I got a little
dangerous with the [ __ ] wings and had
the grilled cheese sandwich I think it
was just too much for a [ __ ] blown
out brain to try to remember what kind
of protein we ordered so she just kept
coming over going house than me she came
over she gave me the burger she gave
Nate the [ __ ] grilled cheese sandwich
way to swing that [ __ ] thing around
the chicken was [ __ ] stone-cold and
she says she started to like turn
sideways when she [ __ ] up the order
and she was like almost trying to hide
behind her own shoulder she was like I'm
sorry I had the manager take it off and
really apologize and she [ __ ]
disappears and comes back two seconds
later which was a big thing in Daytona
ordering food that should have taken at
least fifteen minutes and it returned in
like two seconds it was very disturbing
because the first night when we saw
those [ __ ] old guys with the flabby
arms pushing each other outside that
[ __ ] pizza parlor
[Music]
well I mean I'll take you through the
whole [ __ ] [ __ ] show we went into
this place that we thought was a hooters
a [ __ ] hooters and I'm like I'm not
eating in here any place that that is
sort of in the sex industry it's got one
foot in the sex industry I'm not
ordering food and so I went in there and
got a beer and we walked in and the
chicks didn't have odors but they all
had asses and they had shorts like up
their ass like half their [ __ ] ass
was hanging out and it was just you know
it was a [ __ ] show and we're trying to
figure it out we're like going what the
[ __ ] what the kind of [ __ ] Hooters is
this holders finally admitting that hip
hop went mainstream about 25 years ago
and now they're focusing on asses and it
wasn't till the next day we walked out
we realized it wasn't a hooters it was
some wings joint and I think they're
gonna put Hooters out of business
because I don't think people care about
titties anymore you know I mean plus
you're gonna have a nice rack and like
you your [ __ ] ass can be as flat as a
goddamn [ __ ] desk a desktop right you
know what I mean
so then then I'm winning yeah then you
just got you got to get a pair of tents
you know what I'm gonna do with that I
love an S and you can't have a nice ass
and be out of shape it just doesn't
[ __ ] work that is the nucleus of the
body if that's [ __ ] in shape then
everything else is fine you can have a
[ __ ] pair of tits on you you know
what I mean and then it could just be a
[ __ ] show when you go south you know
what I mean
that's like you know guys when they
[ __ ] they oh they keep lifting
weights you know and they just keep
trying to keep their chests out in front
of their beer belly and then they keep
pushing the jeans down further and
further so they still have their 32 inch
jeans you know by the way I think white
people were the first one to wear saggy
jeans you know I think we were the first
ones to do it and that was with the guys
who just refused to buy a 34 inch then a
36 38 inch waist
they just kept pushing it down and
letting it [ __ ] stomach come out over
the top
so anyways she's like hiding behind her
shoulder going outside the manage to
take it out so she [ __ ] oh no I know
I'm a boy's trying to say yeah how
quickly the food came so the night
before we went out after we left the
[ __ ] the bar where these girls had to
walk around with half of their [ __ ]
asses hanging out and now that I'm a dad
it was even worse I just kept thinking
what if my daughter ends up working this
is for one I wanted to meet the father
of all these guys and be like what did
you do that had them end up here so I
don't do it so my daughter doesn't end
up here so we go down the [ __ ] Street
and we go to this other [ __ ] bar
they're like they got a biker bar down
there cuz they you know Daytona has that
[ __ ] crazy biker week and some [ __ ]
out here and I'm just like I am NOT a
biker and I'm not gonna go in there and
get [ __ ] you know I don't know a pool
cue [ __ ] shoved in my ear I don't
need this [ __ ] right so we go to this
other bar sort of a sports bar we walk
in everything's cool so I ordered some
food I go let me get the what's what's
the raw tuna it's not sashimi is it tuna
tartar tartar is that what I ordered you
know in you know this [ __ ] sports bar
why would you why would you order raw
fish in a place like that it's [ __ ]
nuts but I did and I ordered chips and
salsa and I swear to god this woman
walked into the kitchen they had the in
in the outdoor ulis swinging doors she
walked in there in the door went home
and put it put went puppet and then she
came walking right back out and she with
the [ __ ] food like to suck
disturbingly like it came back so
[ __ ] fast the look on my face
Nate was [ __ ] crying laughing and all
I can say about the food is you
shouldn't have to chew raw tuna it
should be like butter like melts in your
mouth kind of thing and I and I was
chewing the [ __ ] out of it so anyways
back to the [ __ ] other place you know
this is so stupid that I'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] on the food there when you're
sitting in a [ __ ] NASCAR that's been
cut in half and they put a [ __ ] booth
in the middle of it can you really
complain about the food well
I have an hour to fill here so I'm gonna
so this poor woman who you know probably
had some shitty dad she ended up there
with drugs he's trying to get a [ __ ]
order right and you know the guys
walking around mouthing the words moving
on over and this guy in the corner
starts eating this burger dude and I
can't even said the way he was [ __ ]
attacking this burger
I was crying laughing and I had to let
you know I had to do like that you know
you know with somebody and you're the
person you're laughing it kind of
catches you looking at him and then you
want your friend to look at him too so
you got to do like that kind of that
stretch thing where you look back
fortunately it was a flat-screen TV
above his head and I just sort of like
without even like I've been toilets just
for like just turn around look at the TV
you know did like one of those things
and dude the way this guy would say he
attacked this burger like he lunged at
it rather than like it was almost like
his it was someone else was holding it
was the way he was trying to steal a
bite as somebody else's burger that's
the way this guy was eating like his
first bite into the burger he [ __ ]
lunged at it so hard he hit himself in
the face with like the lettuce there
this big piece of like [ __ ] romaine
lettuce hang enough to sell whatever the
[ __ ] it was iceberg lettuce and when he
lunged in it like it [ __ ] hit him in
one of his eyes and he had to stop in
blink and then he just [ __ ] he came
up higher and just lunged at it again he
was eating it like a like a [ __ ]
komodo dragon you know they just sort of
[ __ ] lunge it's something he just
just saw and rip away as if was a
[ __ ] animal and every time he would
lunge at this thing it was I could not
look at him and I was crying laughing of
course by three bites he looked over and
he caught me looking at him laughing and
then I looked at Nate and I pointed at
the menu like I was laughing like oh my
god they have chicken fingers isn't that
hilarious like I was trying to somehow
get away from it but long story short
the grilled cheese was all right the
[ __ ] wings were horrific even when
they were actually heated up they
clearly made him hours ago the way they
came over [ __ ] ice-cold and then they
brought me some hot ones
three seconds later and so the lady
comes over and she picks up our check
she walks over the register and the in
in that short amount of time she already
forgot what we were sitting and then
when she came back
you know Nate picked up the check she
gave it back to me it was just was
[ __ ] horrific man but other than that
Daytona Beach was beautiful we did a
show that night every gonna be like what
are you [ __ ] on [ __ ] Daytona for
because because that's what I saw
I didn't know where to go so anyways I I
played the I want to say Peabody Theatre
because where I'm from that's how you
say Peabody Peabody theater it's like
when you when you're in New York it's
Carnegie Hall and when you're in
Pittsburgh it's Carnegie all right when
you're in Massachusetts it's it's
Peabody and everywhere else it's Peabody
so we played the Peabody Theatre I had a
great time did an hour and 20 minutes
you know all new [ __ ] [ __ ] that got left
off of other hours just had a great
[ __ ] time the crowd was awesome
got a bunch of heckles but they were all
great I liked I liked that [ __ ] I don't
mind what people yell out you know to a
point I don't mind it and I had a good
time and I made a point of saying that
because sometimes people in the crowd
was sorry for all the [ __ ] heckles I
enjoy it I don't mind a lively drunk ass
crowd I'm a [ __ ] drunk okay and now
that I've [ __ ] on everybody you know
that I met basically in a 12-hour period
in Daytona let's talk about the we went
to the race the next day and by the way
thank you to everybody who came out to
the show I mean was such a big [ __ ]
event the next day I mean they should
have been three people in the crowd to
the fact that it was sold out was [ __ ]
amazing so thank you to everybody I will
definitely be back
but I will not be eating at that [ __ ]
place with the cars that are sawed it in
half
so anyways plowing out here so the next
day we go to the race and we weren't
really thinking that there's gonna be
250,000 [ __ ] people
that's like two and a half Rose Bowls
all descending on the same [ __ ] the
same place so all the locals are going
like oh man I'm just staying in tomorrow
that's gonna be a [ __ ] show blah blah
blah blah blah
and when I had driven from the airport
you know when you get off what's so
[ __ ] cool when you get off at the
airport you can actually hear them racin
you know I think there was a truck race
or some [ __ ] like that if you land you
know I didn't get into like [ __ ] 1:00
in the morning at midnight actually so
the race was already over but when they
got there you could hear them racin you
pull out you can see the [ __ ] Daytona
International [ __ ] Speedway which is
amazing right legendary place and as
you're driving by this all these [ __ ]
people in RVs and all that hanging out
wait to go on the race and through these
people do not [ __ ] around the way they
were doing it up like it's the way I
wish we did it at the Rose Bowl like
I've never seen so many like I mean
legit like you could you could like a
rockstar could tour in some of these
[ __ ] mobile homes and the setups that
they had in the [ __ ] flat-screen TVs
you know on the outside with the
generator and they had smokers going and
everybody just having a great [ __ ]
time waiting for this race to happen and
evidently people who Park on the infield
can get there like something like a week
or ten days they've just been in there
these guys are [ __ ] driving around
the track you know getting ready to go
to the race and all that you know
testing out their cars and [ __ ]
qualifying for pole position or whatever
the [ __ ] is that they're doing these
people are sitting there like you mean
though that's that those are diehard
fans right so we ended up calling a
[ __ ] the venue the night before
hooked us up with this guy this driver
and he knew all these back ways to get
there which was a godsend and he got us
like right to where it says Daytona
International Speedway
and Nate bargatze is like hooked up with
some of those NASCAR guys and they came
by about 20 minutes later picked us up
in this little golf cart and just gave
us the
the total VIP treatment and this is the
one thing I will say about NASCAR versus
the NFL is the level of fan access to
all these different you can you can walk
right down onto pit row we were sitting
on the track before the race like a
couple hours before the race they let
you go up there everybody was like
taking pictures at the finish line and
[Music]
one thing I couldn't believe was how
[ __ ] small it is as far as the width
of it it's like these people will go 3
side by side 200 miles an hour they're
out of their minds you got to be right
down there on pit row I met Mario
Andretti got to shake his hand and that
was another thing to like that's just
the array of like famous people that
were there
I guess the appeal of NASCAR was [ __ ]
nuts like you'd see Mario Andretti which
makes sense racecar driver
I saw Gronkowski guy fieri
who else
there was some [ __ ] model this
gorgeous model there Keanu Reeves
LaDainian Tomlinson it was just [ __ ]
it was like all over the [ __ ] map and
you'd see like oh that guy he's the
senator or a [ __ ] you know whatever
South Carolina we got to go in and you
know we got to sit in on like the
drivers meeting and all of that which is
really [ __ ] interesting I thought it
was just gonna be the drivers in like
four of us but it's this giant [ __ ]
room where they let this whole crowd go
into it's just sitting there talking to
the drivers going alright you know it's
been a lot of trying to bump guys off
the track into the [ __ ] stands you
got to stop doing that I mean I don't
know I didn't even know what they would
say I was kind of sitting behind the
guys so I couldn't quite hear but I mean
I can't imagine going to like a [ __ ]
any NFL game and he got to hear the
referees talking to the head coaches
before the game you know the NFL's like
that goddamn CIA you can't get anywhere
near anything so we ended up watching
the race from the infield
and you know I knew some people there so
you at one point we were with the people
from Cisco brewery down on Nantucket if
you ever go to Nantucket crazy good beer
and then they got this vodka they have
like this blueberry vodka and cranberry
vodka that you [ __ ] ladies gonna love
and we hung with them for a while and
then we also were at this other [ __ ]
place and our view was absolutely insane
it was a bunch of [ __ ] I don't know
crashes and cautions it's [ __ ] race
took forever but I don't know I can't I
still can't believe that I got to go go
to it but thank you to everybody in
NASCAR for hooking us up and I'm trying
to remember who the [ __ ] one was a Kyle
Busch now Busch one right I went there
and I just rooted for [ __ ] Dale
Earnhardt jr. jr. you know it's been so
long since I watched a NASCAR I'm like
is Jeff Gordon still Racing's like
knives retired like everybody I knew was
gone like I watched it big time in the
early [ __ ] 80s late 70s early 80s when
it was like Bobby Allanson cale
yarborough Harry Gant Richard Petty
I saw him win like his last Daytona 500
in like 81 or something then Cale
Yarborough one or two years in a row
then it was a Bill Elliott era and I
don't know somewhere around then I was
trying to get through college and I
started doing stand-up and I kind of
lost touch with it but I still paid
attention right through the Dale
Earnhardt years and I don't know I
haven't watched it in a minute but it's
it's [ __ ] amazing dude the whole
thing it was just such an amazing
experience in I don't know maybe I'll go
to Talladega who knows I think that ones
in May we'll see but the big thing I was
excited about was the fact that uh I was
able to do like an hour and twenty
minutes and not bore people [ __ ] that
they'd already heard before so you know
that's like the big fear when you go
back out on the road after you had a
special come out as you like all right
how do I [ __ ] do a bunch of new [ __ ]
without [ __ ] these people over sorry
I'm adjusting the microphone here
without [ __ ] these people over and
I'm still thinking that I was funny
especially after going on after Nate
bargatze who by the way is
one of like six people that got half
hours on on Netflix I think Netflix is
trying to do like the HBO one night
stands so he was running his ready to
tape special in front of me and that
guy's one of the best joke writers I
know and he [ __ ] murdered so I was
relieved that I was able to go on after
him and have a good time so anyways is
it time yeah how about a little bit of
advertising here everybody all right
where are we wandering the [ __ ] is this
stuff I've never heard this one
wandering here's a podcast you should
listen to wait a minute some somebody
else's podcast is advertising in my
podcast yeah don't listen to my podcast
listen to this one all right one oh I
remember this [ __ ] this one's actually
sounded cool all right
secrets crimes in audio tape it's a
podcast that has a different story every
week this week's story is called this is
not a Banksy it's about a guy who wakes
up in the morning and realizes Banksy
drew on his ass who the [ __ ] is Banksy
he gets it tattooed and now people want
to collect his ass it doesn't go well it
was it has high production values it's
funny and Mario Lopez is the guest star
go listen to it all right
this is why I like that podcast it's
because it sounds different and also the
copy was nice and short
his Banksy he's an he's an artist right
I only know this because Nia is into all
that [ __ ] let me know he looked this
[ __ ] up so he'd ruin somebody's ass
and then he had a tattooed and now what
who the [ __ ] is Banksy Banksy is an
anonymous English based graffiti artist
political activists and film director
well if it's anonymous how come they
know who he is
of unverified identity oh there you go
there's satyric old street art and
subversive well then how the [ __ ] did
this guy know Banksy drew on his ass man
he's got great work I'm gonna judge him
on the two that are on his Wikipedia
page ah these are amazing
what a talented son of a [ __ ] he must
be really shy so he does this in England
what if it's what if it's somebody from
the royal family and the reason why they
don't say it is because you know
graffitis look down upon by the the
aristocrats you know stop drawing on our
buildings maybe that's who it is so I
guess he'd ruin somebody's ass somebody
who knows him well well I'm surprised
the the Illuminati doesn't kidnap that
dude and his ass and goes tell me who
the [ __ ] Banksy is tell me who Banksy is
or I'll [ __ ] scalp your ass and that
painting and then your ass won't work
and it won't be worth [ __ ] how about
that
no pun intended alright Dollar Shave
Club everybody there's no reason to use
a cheap disposable razor or pay a
ridiculously high price for some
gimmicky thing that's got a laser
pointer with 17 blades make this smart a
choice and join Dollar Shave Club before
Dollar Shave Club
it was either save money and get a
painful shave from a disposable razor
like the ones they give away free at the
gym which felt like shaving with a piece
of [ __ ] glass or pay a fortune for
the latest gimmicky shave breakthrough
you don't need like a laser chin
detectorists 17 more blades of some [ __ ]
now Dollar Shave Club is the best of
both worlds a premium shape at a
disposable price get a close shave let's
go get a close smooth shave every time
and you can't beat the convenience order
price of the club if you haven't tried
to all the shake club yet you're missing
out it's an amazing shape and an
affordable price
there's no smarter choice on the market
and right now they're giving away a
one-month trial for any of their raises
for a dollar with free shipping
and after that it's just a few bucks a
month there's no long term commitments
no hidden fees he can cancel whenever
you want get your $1 trial at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / oh look who's
back everybody it's my favorite it's old
zip are you hiring well are you do you
know where to post your job to find the
best candidates posting your job in one
place that's not enough to find quality
candidates if you want to find the
perfect hire you need to post your job
on all the top job sites and god dammit
now you can with zip recruit accom you
can post your job to twenty two hundred
plus job sites including social media
networks like Facebook or the Twitter
all with a single click find candidates
in any city or industry nationwide just
post once and watch your qualified
candidates roll in tolls it easy to use
interface no juggling emails or calls to
your office quickly screen candidates
rate them and hire the right person fast
find out today why is it no has been
used by Fortune 100 companies and
thousands of small and medium-sized
businesses and right now my listeners
can post the jobs on zip recruiter for
free by going to zip recruiter com / /
that zip recruiter com / / one more time
try it for free go to zip through TOCOM
slash back alright is this the last one
lastly but not leastly up stamps comm
they're always a headliner you know I
use stamps comm anytime I have a host a
poster I need to mail out you know I'm
gonna [ __ ] myself out weekly meeting
the people out there with their bad
tattoos and their sweaty hands postage
rates can have gone up again
that means trips to the post office are
an even bigger hassle man it's so
crowded but thanks to stamps calm you
don't got to worry about that [ __ ]
that's for the [ __ ] peons not you
you're better than that right you're in
a suite eat a little surf and turf
to the [ __ ] orange [ __ ] Jess you
stance come to automatically calculate
and print the correct amount of postage
for every letter or package you sent
Stan stock comp brings all the surfaces
of the US Postal Service right to your
fingertips they'll send you a digital
scale oh my god it's beautiful
automatically calculate exact post äj--
stamps.com will even help you decide the
best class of mail based on your needs
they give you postage discounts that you
can't get at the post office including
three cents off every first-class stamp
right now use my code Barbie you are our
for this special offer four week trial
that includes postage and a digital
scale scale sorry go to Stan's comm
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in bur that stamps
comm enter BER and sign up today with
stamps com you'll never a with stamps
cough calm you'll never have to go to
the post office again or listen to me
read out loud again during this [ __ ]
podcast alright let me let me select all
of this and then delete it so I can get
to the [ __ ] questions for this week
Dollar Shave Club what was the first one
the first one was the the Banksy Banksy
[ __ ] tattooed my ass alright oh by
the way everybody I mentioned lately
that I'm gonna be starting to post some
videos up to my YouTube my YouTube page
I'm in a bunch of videos from the
Daytona 500 I'm gonna have @ww
youtube.com slash users slash Monday
morning podcast I'm gonna give the
[ __ ] video to my guy this week he's
gonna edit it and get the [ __ ] up there
okay I'll tweet about it when it gets up
there alright so speaking of stamps
I bought some stamps today I did not use
stamps calm I was driving from Daytona
Beach up here to Gainesville and rather
than going like the highway way I took
the longer route cuz I want to see some
[ __ ] right like going by this [ __ ] my
brother told me it's called folk art I
guess I drove by this woman's house of
this guy's house I don't why I thought
it was a woman but you don't have like a
giant Tyrannosaurus Rex a [ __ ] bull
like kicking his legs up like all these
giant
things that you can put on your [ __ ]
lawn I guess I don't know what all this
crazy stuff that you don't see that when
you take 75 north it's just gonna be a
bunch of our bees we got the meats it's
gonna be the same [ __ ] ten chains in
a goddamn Walmart I've seen that a
zillion times but if you if you take the
old school the the [ __ ] route 66 Jack
Kerouac ways it takes longer but you see
a bunch of cool [ __ ] so I was [ __ ]
driving along there and I came upon a
post-office and lo and behold I had a I
had a built that I need to pay and I
didn't have a [ __ ] stamp so I [ __ ]
pull in and the locals they're in there
and I'm listening to this guy tell his
[ __ ] hilarious story first of all I
love the pace of it too I love the pace
of a small town where I don't give a
[ __ ] that this guy's telling a story
he's such a [ __ ] character I'm
enjoying it I'm already second in line
because there's nobody [ __ ] there
right and he's telling his story about
how somebody cut him off you know and
it's not driving too fast and then the
woman behind the counter then tells her
story about how she was doing 15 someone
pulled out in front of her and her son
and his son blew the horn and when they
pulled up next to him at a red light the
guy [ __ ] had a pistol and he [ __ ]
just brought it up looking at him like
you know pointing at the ceiling of his
car he just sort of brought it up like
that and then the guys like he goes you
can't do that
can't do that I write that that's a
terrorist act that's brandishing
brandishing a weapon and you start
talking about brandishing a weapon you
can't do that that'll make somebody want
to you know do some sort of self-defense
that's what I was saying and I was just
like this is [ __ ] crazy out of it I
could but actually I think that they
said that that happened up in Charlotte
or something like that I guess the road
rage is off the [ __ ] chains in
Charlotte North Carolina that's what I
love about a small town I never would
have heard that you know just [ __ ]
guy with his white Uncle Jesse beard
tell his story brandishing a weapon and
I was just sitting there totally not
even giving a [ __ ] that I was standing
in line at the post office completely
enjoying this story and praying to God
that this guy then took out his weapon
because I wanted I wanted to see where
this was going to go next but you know
didn't say anything like I should have
got his license plate and bla bla bla
bla bla I don't know I think that's why
I stay off the 75 north cuz I never
would have heard that you know if I
stayed on the 75 north I would have
heard you know can I get the [ __ ] can
I get a double cheeseburger with the
bucket little blue I don't hear that
[ __ ] oh I know a lot of you guys are
expecting me to talk about the Oscars
but I didn't watch him okay
I don't watch award shows unless I'm
home if I'm home
then my wife's watching him and then I
watch him with her because I like making
fun of him while she watches them
because it makes her mad she doesn't get
mad mad but she gets like upset but I
heard about the big big [ __ ] thing
there in the end where Warren Beatty
came out he's like a little winner for
Best Picture 2017 goes to lala land and
evidently the poor people from lala land
went up there were two speeches in
before they realized that it was
actually going to moonlight starring
simple syrup Shepherd and Bruce Willis I
believe I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened all I know is once I heard that
that happened I didn't want to watch it
you know I don't like much of people
like that level of [ __ ] awkwardness
you know and just seeing Warren Beatty
be that [ __ ] old
I just realized his last [ __ ] name
was what that [ __ ] robot was saying
on clothes and kid not Close Encounters
what was that what was that stupid
[ __ ] Buck Rogers when they had that
little stupid [ __ ] robot go baby baby
is he saying baby baby baby baby me
there was a stupid it like somebody came
up but someone who's sitting in a
[ __ ] writers room and they're like
alright Star Wars is all the rage we got
to somehow make money off this art we're
gonna do Buck Rogers that doesn't seem
that bad I mean it was around before
Star Wars and one of the things we got
to have like an r2d2 ain't a c-3po and
the network's like well we're not
[ __ ] iron two actors it's gonna be
too expensive combined both characters
and stick a [ __ ] [ __ ] and that
goddamn suit alright alright
well c-3po is kind of a [ __ ] smart
[ __ ] with an English accent I'll just
have this thing be a [ __ ] you just see
it as a catchphrase why not what's the
catch well you [ __ ] come up with it
and the writers are probably so pissed
there let's just come up with a dumbest
[ __ ] we can possibly say and see what
this [ __ ] industry person says I a
little [ __ ] he looks like a little
kid George Washington but he's painted
all silver and he's made out of metal
and before he talks he walks around he
goes Beatty Beatty Beatty you know and
then they just sat there they kept the
[ __ ] straight face and that's one of
those moments in life you know when you
throw it on the table you know you're
looking at that person and they're
looking at you and it becomes one of
those moments where whoever talks first
loses and you just [ __ ] wait it out
and then the [ __ ] person goes all
right yeah go with that they're like
great awesome well let's go do some
cocaine it's not [ __ ] addicting right
it's [ __ ] the late 70s yeah so I
didn't I didn't see I didn't see any of
it sorry I know I got a bunch of tweets
can't wait to hear your take on the
Oscars I did not see what I did see was
that the [ __ ] Boston Bruins won again
won again and all my [ __ ] whining
about whining about uh you know them
getting rid of close Julian
according to Bob beers the Bruins are
playing much looser and more confident
under butch Bruce Cassidy SARS I say
butch Bruce Cassidy said what the new
man on the bench the Boston Bruins look
like a new team the B's are six and one
since Bruce Cassidy took over as interim
coach averaging four goals per game
while scoring the first and six of those
contests they exploded for six goals and
Sunday's matinee went over the stars but
the star sucked this year and
98.5 the Sports Hub Bruins analyst Bob
beard says he's seen a much looser and
more confident team take the ice since
Cassidy took over foreclosure lien they
have a little more leash and a little
more freedom to make some plays not to
the point where they're being reckless
or carried away leaving themselves
exposed at the other end but they're
encouraged to play more offensively I
got to tell you man they've been playing
great so I don't know what it is
so you know I guess I was wrong I still
think Claude Julian's a [ __ ] great
coach what are you gonna do maybe maybe
everybody needed to change you know
maybe that's what it is like you stay
with the same person for a while
he just gets sick of them you know and
this is like the new girlfriend you're
all excited you can go all the old
places but it's new for the both year to
go there
I don't know well all I know is it's
[ __ ] working and I absolutely loved
loved the Boston Celtics not making a
move before the trade deadline I think
that was [ __ ] genius it was it would
have been so [ __ ] stupid to give up
draft picks and and some players that we
had you know that they were gonna want
like Marcus smart and [ __ ] Jae
Crowder and a bunch of draft picks at
the very least we were gonna have to
[ __ ] give up that to bring in hookah
Melo Anthony you know who's gonna he's
gonna tell [ __ ] everybody to clear
out and then not get back on D you don't
need that [ __ ] and even if he got us
past the Cavaliers why not no you know
we've beaten the [ __ ] warriors this
year we're certainly not you give up all
of that [ __ ] to do what come in second
place instead of fourth who gives a [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] this is the Boston
Celtics we got to win another
championship the Lakers are lying about
the amount of [ __ ] Champions
Championships they have they patted
their resume with one we need to win
another one put a little distance
between them and I think this [ __ ]
move right here being patient enough to
just say no we're staying the goddamn
course we got all these draft picks you
know who knows maybe that kid from Duke
comes out tatum maybe he's one and done
who knows and you know they got that it
was that other kid and some kid on
Kansas I guess he's like a point guard
or something like that I don't know what
the [ __ ] we need I don't know [ __ ] about
basketball but I love not giving in to
the stupid pressure that you know you're
supposed to make a move you know that'll
make you better in the short run but
[ __ ] you [ __ ] over all the work you've
been doing over the last three four
years so Danny age Danny age love it
absolutely love it all right let's do
some reads for this week because I'm
actually gonna drive down to Tampa
tonight and I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go to the [ __ ] Tampa Bay
Lightning versus the [ __ ] Ottawa
Senators game tonight now but never been
to a game now we'll see how it is all
right four reads all right this is what
I got here
Oh four reads was the advertising it's
not four questions let me get rid of
that okay boyfriend birthday gift hey
there Billy birthday boy my boyfriend my
man recently celebrated a birthday and I
contemplated for weeks what I would get
him after listening to many podcast
episode I picked up on your advice to
freshly single men get yourself all the
sports packages I took old Billy boy's
advice and bought my guy a subscription
for NHL TV holy [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
angel for the remainder of the hockey
season parentheses go pens that's great
- so he and his team is a contender so
it'll be fun to watch and NFL Sunday
Ticket for the upcoming football season
he's beyond thrilled
of course he is thanks for the laughs
and most importantly thanks for the
birthday suggestion all right ladies did
you hear that you know what's great
about all of that [ __ ] is it's so
[ __ ] easy to do that's one phone call
you don't have to go out and go shop you
know let's go get something [ __ ]
engraved it's perfect and if anybody
wants to outdo this woman you know what
you do is you get them the perfect chair
to sit there and watch you know and then
what you do is you get life insurance
and as he slowly eats and drinks himself
to death watching all these sports you
know you got to win either way
either he's gonna be around and he's
gonna be this big lovable [ __ ] you
know grizzly bear over there watching
his games or he's gonna [ __ ] die and
you're gonna get paid you know there you
go good for you that's that's a great
guy I would love that I would that I
would be thrilled with that gift all
right who versus whom a little
aristocrat [ __ ] conversation here the
actual rule I always get these confused
and I love that you guys are gonna
[ __ ] help me out here because I
actually use whom the other day somebody
told me that when you use who is is if
you could substitute it with
he or she but if you're talking about a
day or us or soliloquy then you use home
I don't know
anyways he said the actual rule to use
who with the subject and whom oh the
actual rule is to use who with the
subject in whom with the object so it's
the subject like a person no I don't
I'll never get this done it's like live
versus lay the baby on the bed lies down
but when you put the baby on the bed the
baby is laid down alright like how is
that supposed to help me alright let's
try to figure out the subject in the
object oh my god I'm gonna start [ __ ]
hyperventilating this takes me back to
high school we call on you like I don't
know I don't know just give me a [ __ ]
zero Jesus Christ I mean [ __ ] times
you got to call on me I don't know the
answer before you figure out it you call
on somebody else quarterback keeps
throwing to somebody they keep dropping
the ball they they they go to somebody
else [ __ ] idiot punt
alright the baby on the bed lies down
alright so the baby is to subject is the
bed the object but when you put the baby
on the bed that's an object the baby is
laid down alright well what the [ __ ] who
laid the baby down versus Billy blue
balls laid whom down alright I got
slowed down who laid the baby down who
laid the baby down you did you did shoot
that poison arrow through my shoot that
poison arrow thank you goodnight took me
back I always sing that song to Nia I
always say whoever sings that [ __ ]
song you know that they close with it
and then that's how they end that song
that's how they end it they go shoot
that poison arrow
shoot that poison arrow thank you good
night you know the surprise ending oh I
think you're gonna go through my heart
again
but you didn't all right so who laid the
baby down all right
versus Billy balls laid whom down
okay who laid the baby boy so if I went
like who drank all this [ __ ] beer
Billy blue balls was who drank all the
beer I can't [ __ ] do it who drank all
this beer how come I can't plug that in
alright well somebody said something
about a baby I have a baby in my life so
I have a chance I can at least get that
one right now Jesus sent right back down
to the minors yeah once again he grounds
into an inning-ending double play
[ __ ] kill that goddamn dream I don't
understand I just don't [ __ ] get this
has been explained to me 50 million I
never understood how [ __ ] planes flew
and then I got my pilot's license and
they think they were able to [ __ ]
explain it to me who laid the baby down
[Music]
versus Billy blue balls laid who down
all right so I'm the subject in the
first one and then then what the baby
becomes an object like are you talking
[ __ ] about my kid here believe blue
balls laid home down the actual rule is
to use who with the subject and whom
with the object so I'm more important
than my kids so I'm the object here is
that what I'm done on the subject but
they know that doesn't mean it can you
sense because the King has subjects and
they have to do whatever the [ __ ] they D
tells them I'll tell you right now I
don't I don't feel any closer to the
finish line that I was Jesus the amount
of empathy that I have for all the
[ __ ] teachers in my life that this is
the [ __ ] putty they're trying to mold
into something
alright you know what's great for Great
Barrier Reef for fucksakes bill stop
saying the Great Barrier Reef is dying
get your pasty white Ranger arse down
here get in the water and have a look
for it it's not dying yeah it is you
can't
what do you assign time gone about what
the [ __ ] scientist is saying and I
wanted to go [ __ ] nuts snorkeling
over they said you better do it now
because they're not gonna let people go
there much longer if you don't know what
a Ranger is that we Aussies called
redheaded [ __ ] like you
Ranger being short for orangutan oh I
guess and that cute well you know what
maybe you can say that to me next time I
come down there and do a [ __ ] show
alright why don't you do that I don't
give a [ __ ] you think I give a [ __ ] what
some [ __ ] lives at the bottom of the
[ __ ] world with like three-quarters
you goddamn country you can't even go to
the entire middle of that [ __ ]
content is you continent you can't even
live that what else do you do on
Australia Day do you drive around in
your poor excuse for a [ __ ] El Camino
anyways oh that's he's one of those
[ __ ] guys it's fine it's still
[ __ ] there you know I'm gonna look
this [ __ ] up right now alright Great
Barrier Reef let me see what I get let
me guess because it doesn't agree with
you then it's gonna be fake news Great
Barrier Reef dead the Great Barrier Reef
is not actually dead CNN dramatic oh
I've got what about dying
let me see dying dying let me see dying
corals are dying on the Great Barrier
Reef scientists have discovered an
unprecedented die-off of the world's
largest reef the Great Barrier Reef
prompt yeah there you go right there
okay Great Barrier Reef not dying
Australia insists oh I get it this is
your big tourist attraction this is your
ferris wheel so you want people to keep
flying down there so they can jump in
the water with a bunch of great white
sharks because there's nothing to see on
land down there because three-quarters
of your [ __ ] country is unlivable and
God knows if you go out there it's so
[ __ ] unlit that's why they're snakes
and everything down there is so [ __ ]
poisons because there's such a lack of
dude that that a snake if it just grazes
somebody they got to make it count
because God knows they're not gonna see
anything else aníbal for [ __ ] weeks
Australia insists that it's not [ __ ]
dying I love it okay well that's [ __ ]
credible that's how you make all your
money all those [ __ ] [ __ ] going down
there and there's scuba gear because
they learned how to hold their breath
and breathe underwater and a [ __ ]
swimming pool and they got themselves a
little scuba card and now they're gonna
go into God's swimming pool a [ __ ]
ocean all right that's got all this [ __ ]
that can kill oh my god that's what it
is okay I get I'm sorry I was [ __ ]
with you tourist attraction that they'll
be like you guys down there saying that
the sea can't go up into the arm of the
Statue of Liberty anymore it's gonna
snap off it is dying you stupid [ __ ]
alright alright anyways I absolutely
believe that it is why wouldn't it be
all this [ __ ] that we're doing why would
everything else is [ __ ] dying
everything else is completely [ __ ]
but that isn't maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm
wrong let me you know what I actually I
looked it up let me look up not dying
let's see what this said Great Barrier
Reef but if this is all from [ __ ]
Australia I'm not buying it Great
Barrier Reef not endanger me a big
picture of [ __ ] Trump scuba diving
the Great Barrier Reef not quote
endanger tourism and mining groups have
welcomed a whatever recommendation that
the Great Barrier Reef be left off the
world heritage in danger yeah touring
tourism mining these people all make
money off it should the great be Barrier
Reef be listed as in danger UNESCO Great
Barrier Reef is not in danger but needs
care UN desperate experts say Great
Barrier Reef is not yeah this is all
because you're not making money off of
it Great Barrier Reef outlook poor but
not in danger this is like what you guys
are doing with the Great Barrier Reef
now is what we do with our food supply
you know it's not the best for you but
it doesn't necessarily cause cancer you
know what buddy I hope you're right I
hope you're right I hope it isn't but I
know gun couldn't goddamn well D you're
not a [ __ ] scientist I know I'm not a
scientist and I know that scientists say
that it is [ __ ] dying but anybody for
what I just did my research for 30
seconds was anybody that makes money off
of it say it says that it isn't so I
don't know can I can you give you can
write me back with the [ __ ]
scientists or some sort of [ __ ] group
of them that don't make money off it are
not getting paid to say that it's
[ __ ] dying it's not dying then then
I'll believe it okay so what a mom I'm
still [ __ ] open-minded all right
Obama news censorship hey mr. bill bill
burr I have listened to the past couple
of podcast where some of your listeners
have messaged in about Obama's supposed
censoring of news media and after a bit
of further research it seems like
they're most likely inaccurate or just
wrong now let me ask you this sir
because I looked it up okay and for what
I can tell it was accurate but what I'm
guessing is you're an Obama fan so now
you're gonna tell me this is fake news
now you just saw where I was able to
look up [ __ ] where it said it was dying
and then it isn't dying and it's just
all what you choose to believe right
while the bill is real the conclusion
that it would cause the shutdown and
silencing of dissenting opinions seems
in incorrect it's supposed to find the
identity when foreign countries are
involved in spreading propaganda to
allow US news sites to know where
information is coming from I have a
liberal bias and improbably overlooking
some things out there you go this guy's
an adult okay you know what I take back
everything I said but it seems like that
the bill is not nearly as bad as certain
sites of making out to be which I would
agree with because that that's gonna be
the Fox News people thanks for the
podcast and the latest special this is
what I would guess which is it's
obviously a total guess because I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm guessing it's not as
bad as people on the right are saying it
is but I am definitely of the belief
that there's always that wiggle
in there that you know is there
preventing something you know that
everybody wants to be prevented which
would be propaganda from our [ __ ]
enemies which I actually don't even
think is that bad
I'm not against hearing their take on
things but it would also allow them it's
kind of like you know after 9/11 where
it was just like we need to listen we
need to be able to listen to and on
people's phone conversations but if
you're not doing anything wrong
you know it's then a [ __ ] love you
know it's this is just for terrorists
and then it just becomes a way for them
to spy on you even more and then years
later you see that whole [ __ ] Snowden
thing and he's taken off basically
saying I'm not gonna help you guys build
this thing the greatest nerd of all time
is that Snowden guy you know as opposed
to his other [ __ ] [ __ ] who just
keep [ __ ] you know I've always said
it you know total psychos like a
complete psycho
has no [ __ ] power you know without
nerds nerds give them the ability to be
a cycle on a psycho on a [ __ ] global
level okay is is nuts as Trump is as
Dutch as [ __ ] Hillary is as Dutch as
[ __ ] Bush it's not just all these
[ __ ] lunatics are then that [ __ ]
without nerds creating the technology
for them to you know go psycho on a
global [ __ ] level I mean if it wasn't
for [ __ ] nerds we'd still be
attacking each other with sticks you
know I couldn't figure out how to make a
gun all right lost my 401k hey Bill well
to cut to the chase I'm 51 years old
divorced son is in jail for hitting his
mother who was a lunatic Jesus Christ
and I received a forty nine thousand
dollar settlement and it blew it all on
the California Lottery this can't be
real I really feel like throwing in the
towel can you tell me what you would do
if you were in my awful shoes all right
if this is even remotely real let's yeah
that's probably fake but whatever I can
I can but other people have completely
[ __ ] up their lives so I'll talk to
them and you sir if you're actually
telling the truth
the biggest thing you got going for
yourself is you know that you're a [ __ ]
and you [ __ ] up your life so I would
sit down and I would look at the
decisions that I've made figured out why
I made those [ __ ] decisions I refuse
to believe that you're dumb enough to
get $49,000 and spend all of it on the
California Lottery I would think that
some of it went to bear someone went to
Wade come on somebody get forty nine
thousand bucks you can get yourself a
new truck I mean come on I don't know
can you tell me what you would do if you
were in my office shoes I would get a
[ __ ] job first of all I would stay
away from that stay away from your
ex-wife your sons in jail for hitting
your mother so that would mean he's of
age so you're not paying any child
support so maybe there's some alimony I
don't know I try to teach my son not to
hit my mother I mean I'm a mother like
my not to hit his mother
I don't you got water coming in from all
sides here I don't know what to tell you
if you get money I would save it rather
than gamble it away and but you're only
51 years old dude this is what I would
do I would start would start p90x it get
a little bit of [ __ ] self-esteem and
have a little more belief in yourself
that you can make it other than trying
to do a [ __ ] night zillion to one
shot which you tried to cut down to 49
thousand to 49,000 shots and a billion
to one
yeah dude I don't know what to tell you
man I think you're gonna be fine you 51
years old you know he's still got you
guys still got some years ahead of you
but I would just I wouldn't throw my
[ __ ] money away like that I mean I
don't know how to give you advice if you
blew all your money on lottery tickets
but I don't want you to throw in the
towel you know what I would do I would
write a [ __ ] book stare into it you
know like it's the comics comic you
might be the losers
loser write a [ __ ] book about it you
know we'll make some YouTube videos and
just tell your [ __ ] story get some
advertising right maybe you can make a
little bit of money that way [ __ ] it's
easy to make 49 thousand bucks off the
[ __ ] Internet there's enough people
that people love people failing you who
the [ __ ] failed more than you turn it
around turn that failing into a [ __ ]
positive tell your [ __ ] story start
going around to schools telling people
what not to do I don't know what you
should do but don't do what I did right
that's a country lyrics they always
they're always doing that [ __ ] like I
was thinking of the drive over here talk
about this person in front of me was
driving so slow is like Jesus Christ you
got all the time in the world and I'm
like that's such like a country lyric
that they would flip around you know I
got all the time in the world then I
don't want to go on living you know you
say it's a juxtaposition there
you don't mean it's like I got all this
time my hands but I don't want any time
because I'm a my woman left me or
something like that right so I clean up
[ __ ] but bull wants to [ __ ] a cow but
I ain't under around but a pig you
normally it's one of those type of
things I would just stare into it sir
now we turned it into entertaining
stories to somehow tell them but I'm
also a comedian that that's what the
[ __ ] I would do other than that I would
stay away from your ex-wife and I don't
know I don't know what to do with you
son try to set a better example by not
blowing all your money on lottery
tickets maybe that's that's the thing I
don't know sorry you're in that
situation if you actually are alright
text sent to the wrong person at work oh
Jesus this is never good
dear Billy graham cracker tits
[Music]
I never thought I'd be in a situation
where I needed to write into you like
this
but Here I am in a pinch for the last
couple of years certain people at my
work have been getting very relaxed with
their work ethic and punctuality so much
so that another co-worker and I have
written an album of songs about its
absurdity since our office is well maybe
could write a song about the guy who
just wrote in above me you know you guys
you know then you go on American Idol I
don't know anyway since ours is an
office of about 10 people everybody's
job directly relates to everyone else's
and it puts extra strain on the rest of
us recently two of the worst offenders
both ladies not that it matters have
actually but I mentioned it have
actually gotten promotions for some
reason with that said this morning I
noticed one of the ladies accomplished a
quote task in our project manager to
bring food to an office potluck lunch
being the snarky [ __ ] I am I took a
screenshot to send to my like-minded
co-worker with the text quote think and
then the person's name is going a little
overboard here somehow she only creates
to do she can get done can't get [ __ ]
done for work but for food the [ __ ] is
all over it well I didn't hear back from
him after 10 minutes I felt this first
wave of panic
I knew it immediately the text had been
sent to the lady yeah cuz what happens
is you're thinking about that person and
you're thinking about their name and you
know my god we've all done this
completely flustered I sent a flurry of
apology text but she didn't respond all
this was happening around 8:30 which is
when people are supposed to arrive this
worker usually shows up around 9:45 or
10:00 but that's beside the point what
can you unsend the text I don't notice
some nerd know how to do that anyways
after I didn't hear from her I checked
the calendar and saw that she was on
vacation for the next 10 days no but I
know she got the text and now I'm
worried about what she thinks and
whether it's going to be weird in the
office what do I do
she's not a bad person and when you
called her a [ __ ] too and I have to
work with her regularly before realizing
she was out I already bought flowers and
put them on her desk in order to cover
the stench of my own failure now dude
you can't he got because she knows what
you really think
I'm guessing I shouldn't leave them
there and let her come back two dead
flowers either congratulations on your
baby girl and of course your latest
special sincerely I done [ __ ] up
where is she on vacation and is there a
way to unsend all of those text messages
that's what I would try to do over the
next 10 days I would not apologize
anymore I would not give flowers and
this is what you got to do dude you got
a [ __ ] man up and when she calls you
out on it be like yep I was I'm not
gonna tell you who I was sending it to
don't rat out the other person on any
[ __ ] level do not rat out the other
person you piece of [ __ ] if you do it do
not rat them out I would actually say I
was actually sending it to this girl I
know who doesn't work here okay just say
that and I always [ __ ] to her about
people at work and it what she calls
young I would just say listen you know
what no sense sugarcoating it you're
supposed to be here at 8:30 you show up
at 9:45 10 o'clock
you dog in it he's setting a bad example
and I like working hard and that text
came from the frustration of watching
you working and setting the example of
not working up to your potential it
makes it a bad experience out here so
that that's why I did it if you're mad
at me I understand but you know I stand
by that text message I shouldn't called
you a [ __ ] I was just saying that the
way you know Richard Pryor says that I
was just trying to be funny but you know
you showing up an hour and 15 to an hour
and a half late every day is not good
for the the morale around the office
that's what that's where that came from
so there you go and I'm sorry I sent it
to you but you know that's it [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it that's all that's the only card
you got to play be like yeah I sent it
although you did [ __ ] put your hat in
your hand and apologize yeah boy can you
please write back and let me know how it
pans out I'd love to know all right with
that
that is the podcast for this week
I'll check in on you on Thursday and
this time next week I will be in Phoenix
Arizona
then when two shows a night at a komoti
Club also known as a comedy club and be
[ __ ] polishing up this [ __ ] hour so
I can go on the road and not embarrass
myself like this guy did with his text
message you pull it best we've all been
there you know what even the lady that
you you're writing to I bet she's done
it too but she's letting you squirm or
or she's in Aruba she's someplace where
she didn't get the text message and
maybe you can undo it maybe you can
[ __ ] undo what was already done this
is this is another [ __ ] movie this is
a [ __ ] movie this is like weekend at
Bernie's meets Steve Jobs [ __ ] one of
those things when we used to walk out be
like look now you can swipe texts and
every is like oh right that's what you
do if you get fired sir
you should write a [ __ ] script write
a [ __ ] script about somebody who sent
the wrong text message to their boss
send a text message to the wrong person
that person is on vacation okay and then
eventually you're gonna have to fly down
there you know that you you can co-star
with the guy with the eyes used to the
ice thing that he got from [ __ ] Al
Pacino what was what was the name of
that actor he was in about last Andrew
McCarthy right you guys maybe you can
[ __ ] an executive producer
see that that's the great thing about
entertainment no matter how bad you [ __ ]
up it'll it makes the more you [ __ ] up
in your personal life the more material
you get as a comedian you get a script
out of it I don't know you don't sound
fulfilled maybe maybe you could be a
script writer all right that's it go
[ __ ] yourselves you [ __ ] and I'll talk
to you on Thursday